ich habe heute ein thema mitgebracht was
mich in den morgenstunden sehr verärgert
hat und zwar ist mir aufgefallen dass in
thüringen in einer gießerei die auch die
thüringer allgemeine als erstes
berichtet hat dieses schild außen in
einer firma vor dem pausenpfiff raum und
zwar bisher kein vollständiger
impfschutz dort waren die leute
abgebildet die noch keinen impfschutz
haben mit ihrem namen also die
mitarbeiter ich habe dann zum telefon
gegriffen und den chef der firma
angerufen ich habe jemanden an der
leitung gab der sehr geschämt war und
auch traurig darüber war nicht weil
jetzt darüber geschrieben wird oder
darüber berichtet wird natürlich mit
einem riesigen echo sondern weil er für
seine mitarbeiter eigentlich etwas gutes
tun wollte denn 80 prozent seiner
mitarbeiter seien geimpft und er hat
sich eine lösung überlegt wie wieder
mehr als einer zusammen im pausenraum
sitzen kann in seinen worten klang das
so wir haben ihn aus seinem unternehmen
auch selbst kritisch gesehen auch ich
fühle mich mit dem aushang nicht wohl
aber ich fühle mich auch nicht wohl die
masse meiner leute mit hygiene
schutzmaßnahmen zu drangsalieren die
nicht nötig sind wir haben aktuell eine
gemengelagen die ganz schlecht ist als
unternehmer ist mit aktuell ein
prügelknabe mainzer menschen schützen
aber darf nicht umsetzen wie soll ich
denn mitarbeiter schützen wenn ich nicht
weiß wen ich schützen soll er hat mir
ganz klar im gespräch gesagt dass er gar
nichts gegen die mitarbeiter hat die
nichts geht die nicht geimpft sind man
kennt mich ja die nach acht zuschauer
als jemand der sich über sowas extrem
echauffieren würde aber als ich ein
unternehmer am telefon erlebt habe der
so sehr so ahnung ist der so darüber
nachgedacht hat was jetzt also was daran
falsch weil er wusste ist natürlich aber
das möchte ich mit der gruppe gerne
debattieren ob nicht endlich die
regierung einfach aufheben muss deco
maßnahmen den freedom day einläuten muss
damit sowas einfach nicht mehr passiert
weil der unternehmer hat mir glaubhaft
versichert dass er niemanden seinem
unternehmen schaden wollte also liebe
nina das sind nicht die schnellsten
50 oder 55 minuten des tages für die
zuschauer oder sie wirklich schnellsten
55 minuten das sind auch die
differenzierten 55 minuten ja da eine
brilliante zusammenfassungen im
spannungsfeld eines unternehmers der
sich da in diesem labyrinth der korona
maßnahmen zurechtfinden muss dass das
stimmt ich meine meine sympathie geht
auch zu den unternehmen die das
ausgebaute müssen wir haben leiden
unternehmen hier heute ich bin auch ein
wir stehen da zum teil im schwitzkasten
da diese etwas bis extrem willkürlichen
maßnahmen trotzdem ist und ich meine
jede firma darf das selber so regelung
innerhalb der gesetze und ich meine wie
man das macht ist im grunde seine sache
jetzt ich persönlich finde so sagt rich
und vor allem für die jungen das finde
ich eine ziemlich heftige maßnahme essl
uhr das schöne an der privatwirtschaft
ist ja es gibt auch andere firmen und es
gibt eine auswahl und da kann man ja
wenn man sich daran stört und aus
mitarbeiter kommen ja zum beispiel das
wechseln aber war es eben das große
problem ist wenn der staat solche dinge
an es gibt nur einen start und dann
kannst du nicht entfliehen und darum bei
aller sympathie für den unternehmen wie
er jedoch selbstkritisch ist ich finde
jetzt den rückweg der uns mit lauter
nicht so optimal mit dem staat und der
anprangerung aber ich sehe dass auch
meine meinung dazu ich meine ja sogar
zweig restaurants wer ist so furchtbar
für eine arbeit der unternehmer hatte
mir auch berichtet dass alle mitarbeiter
waren damit der chor also er hat sie
gefragt und dann haben sie
unterschrieben dass es in ordnung ist
wenn ihr name und ihr bild da ist ich
finde diese maßnahme auch völlig absurd
jetzt die augen geschlossen worden die
optimisten die abgewetzten waren dafür
ich denke aber auch der druck ist
natürlich da wenn der chef fragt ist es
in ordnung aber das muss man auch noch
erwähnen die waren wohl dafür dass sie
dort abgewählt werden aber meine frage
war dann ist können ja nicht alle dafür
gewesen sein weil war mich wohler und
angela im netz kinder und die frage ist
ja am ende auch wenn das so anfängt wie
geht es weiter wenn er das ganze auf
fangen wir jetzt an auch dann in einer
firma zu trennen grippe geimpft nicht
grippe geimpft hätte ein arbeitgeber
großes interesse daran im zweifel denn
die grippe ausfälle möglicherweise auch
gerade dieses jahr die sind ganz schön
heftig gehen ganz schön ins geld eines
arbeitgebers also sehen wir dass beide
vielleicht auch bald die gegen röteln
kämpften und die ging nicht rütteln
kämpften dass die sich dann
möglicherweise gegenüber stehen also bei
allem guten willen und ich würde dem
arbeitgeber jetzt auch gar nichts
schlechtes unterstellen dem firmenchef
aber dann habe ich schon dass er ein
massiver spalter ist nämlich ein spalter
seiner belegschaft selbst wenn die das
sogar gut findet aber erteilt in
schlecht und in gut und das ist kein
gutes signal die gesellschaft schneidet
jetzt auch er bekommt nämlich
morddrohungen und ganz furchtbare anrufe
irgendwie dass man ihm wünscht dass er
gegen den baum fährt und dass er sich
schämen sondern so weiter als auch da
sieht man wieder dass hitze potenzial
ich greife das auch an aber das ausmaß
dass er heute beschrieben hat fand ich
dann auch schon wieder heftig und musste
doch leicht widersprechen weil ich meine
im grunde hat der staat das vorgespult
der staat diskriminiert die ungeimpften
der staub machte die
zweiklassengesellschaft und das dann
leute im unternehmen im privaten sektor
sich vielleicht auch etwas unter diesem
druck dann entsprechend verhalten ich
rede sie gewiss kein widerspruch seien
ursachen vorher nicht richtig wäre ein
traum für mich in sachen der schon den
prolog für mich der start der diese
maßnahmen aber dann hat man ja jetzt
wenn ich das vielleicht noch hinzufügen
das hat man ja im fall des
fußballspielers gesehen kenne ich mich
wer hat sich auch nicht impfen lassen
und wird dann vom regierungssprecher
aufgefordert sich impfen zu lassen ihm
wird sozusagen eine vorbildfunktion wir
im fußball und im sport sicherlich hat
aber was die impfbereitschaft angeht
dann vielleicht auch weniger und der
wird auch in gewisser weise an den
pranger gestellt indem man ihm sagt ja
aber sie muss sich jetzt impfen lassen
und wenn er das nicht tut dann ist ein
schlechtes vorbild für das ganze land
das sagen und moralischer druck der da
ausgeübt also müssen ja per se vorbilder
sein oder ja ja ja
eigentlich bestimmt wir sollten nichts
falsch machen wenn man so sagt also ich
bin genesen und geimpft auch mit
überzeugung gekämpft weil es gehabt habe
und dass nicht mehr mehr haben will aber
ich denke auch es geht so weit was
kimmig anbelangt auch ein fußballspieler
wenn er auch vorbild ist wer als schön
wenn er weder geimpft werde natürlich
sollte und darf auch noch der herr
seines eigenen körpers sein und so sehe
es auch es geht mir geht der chef zu
weit das dorf machen und die belegschaft
wusste wer geimpft ist und wer nicht
geimpft ist und wer es nicht sagen will
ja das hat nicht aber
aber so den den freedom day und so das
geht mir stück weit zu weit also der der
ausdruck friede und er jemals so weit
weil ich mittlerweile der festen
überzeugung bin wir können den menschen
wieder allen
die komplette freiheit zurückgeben und
auch die verantwortung für die eigene
gesundheit müssen wir ihnen eigentlich
zurückgeben es gibt impfstoff wir wissen
zum großen teil wie man mit dem virus
umgehen kann alles ist noch nicht
erforscht es gibt die krankenhaus ampel
also ich denke es ist jetzt an der zeit
dass man das ganze
erste weg und ich bin aber der
überzeugung dass manche noch die maske
tragen werden aus vorsicht das ist auch
okay freie entscheidung das freie
entscheidung wenn sie irgendwo sind bei
ihm sogar zum öffentlichen
personennahverkehr und die u bahn s bahn
bus ist proppevoll und ich will das so
dann soll das heute zu machen und ich
denke das werden auch einige tun aber
ansonsten haben wir jetzt eineinhalb
jahre es ist gut wir müssen auch lernen
und leben mit diesem virus umzugehen das
heißt das was ihr ministerpräsident
beispielsweise in bayern möchte nämlich
eine verlängerung auch der epidemischen
lage da würden sie das ganz klar
ablehnen und sagen nein das dass das
können wir nicht mehr machen die
epidemische lager muss auflaufen
auslaufen muss beendet werden und dann
ist sozusagen diese pandemie auch damals
ad acta gelegt
das sind jetzt zwei dinge also dass die
epidemische lage auslaufen soll da bin
ich dafür im august schon sehr kritisch
bei der verlängerung deshalb ist aber
die pandemie noch nicht vorbei und sind
wir das gibt es auch noch man muss den
menschen schon noch sagen leute das ist
nicht vorbei und die krankheit wenn dich
erwischt das ist in vielen fällen auch
nicht einfach also die vorsicht schon
auch darauf hinzuweisen aber die ganzen
einschränkungen sie sollten jetzt den in
die hunte meint der punkt ist ja auch
der ich freue mich die ganze zeit für
wen stellt eigentlich eine ungeimpfte
eine bedrohung dar wenn ich gehen ich
bin auch geimpft es hat einfach keinen
habe ich da keine psycho stress wenn
jetzt einer von habe ich nicht geimpft
ist und wenn wir wenigstens sitzen wir
weit weg wenn ich aufgrund meiner
gesundheit ich eine vor krankheit und da
etwas zur risikogruppe gehört kann ich
mich schützen also ich kann ja auch
ausgeben statt einem ausgetragen man
sagt mir die maske nützen etwas also ich
teile ihre auffassung der stadt geht
viel zu weit reist eigentlich die
verantwortung für die gesundheit von den
menschen an sich jetzt auch wir wissen
besser was sie eigentlich machen ist und
deshalb sich wieder aussteigen jetzt das
geld nicht die leute können doch selber
ihre gesundheit schützen man muss nicht
meinen die sind so dumm dass wir das
verbessern können für die also man ja
auch eine risikoabwägung das muss man
auch sagen es gibt ja im friesischen
unbestrittener weise gibt es im
friesischen und natürlich ist es eine
individuelle entscheidung diese risiken
gegeneinander abzuwägen ich glaube schon
auch dass eine impfung grundsätzlich was
gutes ist auch gerade im fall von corona
aber dass es leute gibt die die
risikoabwägung anders treffen als andere
leute das sollte man vielleicht
akzeptieren zumal es bei der impfung
selbstschutz geht und nicht um den
schutz um den schutz der der
gemeinschaft